Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we are going to take a light simulation
algorithm that doesn’t work too well,
and infuse it with a powerful neural network.
And what happens, bam! This happens. Wow.
So, what was all this about? Well, when we
fire up a classical light simulation program,
first, we start out from…yes, absolutely nothing.
And, look, over time, as we simulate the path of
more and more light rays, we get to know something
about the scene. And slowly, over time, the image
cleans up. But there is a problem.
What is the problem? Well, look.
The image indeed cleans up over time, but no one
said that this process would be quick. In fact,
this can take from minutes, in the case of this
scene, to get this, even days for this scene.
In our earlier paper, we rendered
this beautiful, but otherwise,
sinfully difficult scene and it took approximately
three weeks to finish. And it also took
several computers running at the same time.
However, these days, neural network-based
learning methods are already capable of
doing light transport. Why not use them?
Well, yes they are, but they are not perfect.
And we don’t want an imperfect result.
So, scientists at NVIDIA said that this
might be the perfect opportunity to use
control variates. What are those and
why is this the perfect opportunity?
Control variates are a way to inject our knowledge
of a scene into the light transport algorithm.
And here is the key. Any knowledge is
useful, as long as it gives us a headstart,
even if this knowledge is imperfect. Here
is an illustration of that. What we do is
that we start out using that knowledge,
and make up for the differences over time.
Okay, so, how much of a headstart can we get with
this? Normally, we start out from a black image,
and then, a very noisy image. Now hold on to your
papers, and let’s see what this can do to help us.
Wow. Look at that. This is incredible! This is not
the final rendering, this is what the algorithm
knows, and instead of the blackness, we can
start out from this. Goodness, it turns out that
this might not have been an illustration, but the
actual knowledge the AI has of the scene. So cool!
Let’s look at another example. In this bedroom,
this will be our starting point. My goodness,
is that really possible? The bed and the
floor are almost completely done. The curtain
and the refractive objects are noisy, but
do not worry about those for a second.
This is just a starting point, and it is still
way better than starting out from a black image.
To be able to visualize what the algorithm has
learned with a little more finesse, we can also
pick a point in space, and learn what the world
looks like from this point and how much light
scatters around it. And we can even visualize
what happens when we move this point around.
Man, this technique has a ton
of knowledge about these scenes.
So, once again, just to make sure. We start out
not from a black image, but from a learned image,
and now, we don’t have to compute
all the light transport in the scene,
we just need to correct the differences.
This is so much faster! But actually, is it?
Let’s look at how this helps us in practice. And
that means, of course, equal time comparisons
against previous light transport simulation
techniques. And, when it comes to comparisons,
you know what I want. Yes! I want Eric Veach’s
legendary scene. See? This is an insane scene
where all the light is coming from not here, but
the neighboring room through a door that is just
slightly ajar. And, the path tracer, the reference
light transport simulation technique behaves as
expected. Yes, we get a very noisy image because
very few of the simulated rays make it to the next
room. Thus, most of our computation is going
to waste. This is why we get this noisy image.
And, let’s have a look what the new method
can do in the same amount of time. Wow!
Are you seeing what I am seeing? This is
completely out of this world. My goodness.
Okay, but this was a pathological scene
designed to challenge our light transport
simulation algorithms. What about a more typical
outdoors scene? Add tons of incoming light from
every direction and my favorite, water caustics.
Do we get any advantages here? The path tracer
is quite noisy, this will take quite a bit of
time to clean up. Whereas the new technique…oh
my, that is a clean image. How close is it to the
fully converged reference image? Well, you tell
me, because you are already looking at that. Yes,
now, we are flicking between the new technique
and the reference image, and I can barely tell the
difference. There are some, for instance, here,
but that seems to be about it. Can you tell the
difference? Let me know in the comments below.
Now, let’s try a bathroom. Lots of shiny surfaces
and specular light transport. And the results are…
look at that! There is no contest here. A
huge improvement across the whole scene.
And, believe it or not, you still haven’t seen
the best results yet. Don’t believe it? Now, if
you have been holding on to your papers, squeeze
that paper, and look at the art room example here.
This is an almost unusable image with classical
light transport. And, are you ready? Well, look at
this. What in the world! This is where I fell off
the chair when I was reading this paper. Absolute
madness. Look. While the previous technique
is barely making a dent into the problem,
the new method is already just a few fireflies
away from the reference. I can’t believe my eyes.
And this result is not just an
anomaly. We can try a kitchen scene
and draw similar conclusions. Let’s see.
Now we’re talking! I am out of words.
Now, despite all these amazing results, of
course, not even this technique is perfect.
This torus was put inside a glass container, and
is a nightmare scenario for any kind of light
transport simulation. The new method successfully
harnesses our knowledge about the scene,
and accelerates the process a great
deal, but, once again, we get fireflies.
These are going to be difficult to get rid of
and will still take a fair bit of time. But
my goodness, if this is supposed to be a
failure case…then yes, sign me up, right now!
Once again, the twist here is
not just to use control variates,
the initial knowledge thing,
because in and of itself,
it is not new. I, like many others have been
experimenting with this method back in 2013,
almost ten years ago, and back then, it was
nowhere near as good as this one. So, what is the
twist then? The twist is to use control variates,
and infuse them with a modern neural network.
Infusing previous techniques with
powerful learning-based methods is a
fantastic area of research these days. For
instance, here you see an earlier result,
an ancient light transport technique called
radiosity. This is what it was capable of
back in the day. And here is the neural
network-infused version. Way better. I
think this area of research shows a ton of promise
and am so excited to see more in this direction.
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? I’d love to hear your thoughts,
please let me know in the comments below.
And when watching all these beautiful results, if
you feel that this light transport thing is pretty
cool, and you would like to learn more about it,
I held a Master-level course on this topic at the
Technical University of Vienna. Since I was always
teaching it to a handful of motivated students,
I thought that the teachings shouldn’t
only be available for the privileged few
who can afford a college education, but the
teachings should be available for everyone.
Free education for everyone, that’s what I want.
So, the course is available free of charge for
everyone, no strings attached, so make sure to
click the link in the video description to get
started. We write a full light simulation program
from scratch there, and learn about physics,
the world around us, and more. If you watch
it, you will see the world differently.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!